le débat aurait dû nous permettent de
répondre aux questions parfaitement
légitime et très précise que des
oppositions soulevé des oppositions qui
parce qu'elles ont respecté la
démocratie en choisissant de déposer des
amendements qui porte sur le fond ont
été in fine et privés du débat auquel
elle avait droit
voilà ce à quoi aurait dû ressembler ce
débat
rien à voir avec les dizaines de
milliers d'amendements qui pour
l'essentiel n'avait pas d'autre but que
de bloquer l'examen du texte
rien à voir avec les incidents de séance
à répétition orchestré pour donner
l'illusion de l'action et du débat quand
l'effet recherché était la paralysie je
ne m'étendrai pas sur l'image
particulièrement triste que renvoie de
nos institutions
les événements de ces derniers jours
toutes les oppositions sont légitimes
bien sûr toutes les contestations
doivent évidemment s'exprimer mais il me
paraît qu'elles doivent le faire dans le
respect des institutions et des
pratiques du débat républicain
c'est la raison pour laquelle
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
[Applaudissements]
continuez monsieur le premier ministre
tout le monde garde son calme jeudi
sonne répond provocation je disais si
vous persistez la situation sera évoquée
devant le bureau vous avez la parole
monsieur le premier ministre je disais
donc que c'était la raison pour laquelle
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi et
pour permettre à la suite du processus
législatif de s'engager
nous le savons bien mesdames et
messieurs les députés
bien souvent le recours à l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la constitution a été
utilisée par des gouvernements obligé de
faire face à l'hostilité de leur
majorité sur un texte de loi ou sur une
ligne politique c'est arrivé ça n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
cette majorité dont la diversité est une
chance s'est engagé lors des élections
législatives de 2010 est à créer un
système universel de retraites une des
réformes les plus ambitieuses et les
plus complexes c'est vrai de ces
dernières années je suis pour ma part
fier de cette majorité
fier de sa détermination et de sa
mobilisation sans faille pour tenter de
proposer un débat démocratique à la
hauteur des enjeux
je suis fier qu ensemble depuis juin
2010 sept mois après mois nous ayons mis
en oeuvre le programme de transformation
voulue par le président de la république
des transformations qui parfois
attendait depuis bien trop longtemps
d'être mises en oeuvre à bien des égards
à bien des égards la situation dans
laquelle certains ont voulu nous mettre
aujourd'hui est la preuve que ces
transformations nécessite de
l'abnégation et de la volonté politique